I've created a cluster of things right
here and then I copy and pasted another
cluster and I have a couple of these off
canvas and what I want to do is
represent the number of things we have
in each of these clusters in different
bases and eat in different number
systems so first we're going to do it in
base in base ten sometimes called a
decimal number system decimal you know
the prefix deci it refers to ten decimal
number system when people talk about a
decimal number system they're not just
talking about what we traditionally
associate with decimal numbers to the
right of the decimal point
they're talking about base 10 so in a
decimal number system so the way you
would think about is the way you would
think about really well I mean one way
to think about is how you think about
money if you have a bunch of money or
you're trying to represent a bunch of
money with the smallest possible bills
you'll see them you'll see the biggest
you'll try to figure out the biggest
bill that is smaller than that amount of
money and you would start there if you
wanted to have the fewest number of
bills so over here if we're in base ten
we want to find the biggest power of ten
that fits into however many objects we
have here let's just count it real quick
we have one two three four five six
seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30
31 32 33 34 I might have missed a few
but the bottom line is a hundred does
not go into this but 10 would so we can
divide that the biggest the biggest
power of 10 or the biggest multi power
of 10 I should say that is divisible
into this is 10 so let's divide this
into as many groups of 10 as we can so
let's find let's see this is 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 so let me separate these off so
that is 110 right over there let me make
sure I counted that right 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 let me find another group of 10 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 so this right here is
another group of 10 and then I have 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 so this right here is
another group
of ten and then this over here is not a
group of ten this is just one two three
four five so looks like there's thirty
five objects here so I can represent
these three groups of ten so let me
actually just write down in words first
so we have three tens so we have three
tens well we could have considered three
groups of tens and then in what's left
over I can't divide ten into it so I
have to go down to a lower power of ten
and that's one so how many ones are
there right over here so then we have 1
1 2 ones three ones for ones 5 one so
it's three tens plus five plus five ones
and the way we would represent it in a
base 10 number system we have a tens
place so in the tens place let me write
in the tens place we would write three
and then in the ones place in the ones
place we would write five and so we
would just associate this is 35 but this
is just representing it in a decimal
number system it's we've gotten used to
this but this is just one of really an
infinite number of number systems now
let's do the same thing with the same
cluster but let's do it in base two
let's do it in base base two or where we
can only represent it with two different
digits in base ten you have ten
different digits to play with or you
could call this a binary number system
binary number system you only have two
digits binary number system so what is
the largest power of two that can fit in
this remember we want kind of have the
fewest number of coins or bills so we
want to put the largest power of two
that would fit into this so what would
be the largest power of two so we have
thirty five things so let's see the
largest 2 to the fourth power is 16 2 to
the fifth power is 32 so 32 goes into
this so let's find ourselves a group of
32 one well really we could just exclude
we could just exclude three things so
this right over here this right over
here is a group of 32 so we have one one
thirty twos 30 twos
let me just write it like that and then
we have no 16s no groups of 16s here
and then we have no because 16 can't go
into what's left over
we have no groups of eight we have no
groups of four but then we have groups
of one remembered one is just the low
it's 2 to the zero power so we have we
have 1 2 oh let me be let me be very
careful I skipped one so let me let's
draw our places here so I we looked at
groups of six of 32 32 did go into it
then you go to 16
then you go to 4 4 still can't go into
this remainder right here but 2 can so
now let's do a group of 2 so a group of
2 would look just like that so we have
one twos one twos and then what we have
left over is just one group of ones so
then we have I'm just in a new color one
group of that's not a new color
one group of one's no that's still not
the same having trouble switching color
one group of one so one ones so how many
how would we represent this in base 2
and to do that let's just think about
our places this is the ones place that's
the ones place this is the twos place
that's the twos that is the fours place
let me I'm running out of space here so
this right here is the fours place this
right here is the eights place right
deuce a little smaller so don't bump
into our diagram so that is eight eight
now this right here is 16 s 16 s and
then we're just going up we're
multiplying by 2 in each place as we go
to the left and then this right here is
the 30 seconds place 30 and I'm writing
it out so we don't confuse you know I
could write the the base 10 symbols here
but then that could be kind of confusing
so let me just write the words here to
say that look we're just these are these
are the places and I don't want to use
base 10 to represent base 2 places so we
know from kind of grouping this would be
the largest group we have 132 s so we
write a 1 in the 32 s place there's no
groups of 16 here in the leftover so
there is no groups of 16
there's no groups of eight here there's
no groups of four here there is a group
of two's so there's one group of two's
and then there's one group of ones
one group of ones so 1 0 0 0 1 1 is how
you would represent this number or 30
this number of things or 35 things in
base 2 in base 2 now what I want to do
is take it to the next level base 2 has
fewer digits than what we're used to in
the decimal number system what happens
if we had more digits so let's go to
base 16 and this is fascinating base 16
base 16 or the hexadecimal hexadecimal
number system hexadecimal number system
now I don't have to write number system
hexadecimal and here we're going to have
16 digits so we're gonna have all of the
traditionals digits let me write them
all out we're gonna have 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 and so this is 10 digits right here
but now we're going to extend the number
of digits we can deal with so instead of
having to reuse these digits to
represent 10 we're gonna represent 10
with an A and we're going to represent
11 with a B and represent 12 with a C
and represent 13 with a D represent 14
with an E and then represent 15 with an
F so now we have 16 digits we have 1
through 15 plus 0 remember in base 10
you have 1 through 9 plus 0 so you kind
of have symbols that go all the way up
to whatever your base is so in this
situation you know don't don't be
confused this this a when we're talking
in hexadecimal represents 10 objects
this B would be if I say hey you owe me
B dollars I'm telling you that you owe
me $11 it's just another way to
represent 11 instead of used doing a 1
and a 1 that we would do in base 10 so
if you had these digits how would you
represent this many things so remember
we're in base 16 now so let's draw the
number of spaces so you're always gonna
have your one space
if you know your powers that's 16 to the
zeroth power and then if you multiply
that times 16 you have your 16s place
you have your 16s place because we're in
base 16 or hexadecimal and then if you
go one place more you have your 256
place and I'll write it down but I'll
write it in quotes your 256 place and I
got 256 because that's 16 times 16 or 16
to the second power so how would you
represent this so first of all this 200
and we could keep going up by
multiplying by 16 but does 256 go into
this thing right over here it doesn't we
know we only have 35 things right here
so we don't we won't use we won't use
the 256 place when we represent this
number and so 16 does go into this so
how many groups of 16 do we have here so
let's count it out let me do it with a
new color so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 so hopefully I didn't lose
any so that's one group of 16
let me count it again 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 so that's one group
of 16 let's get another group see if we
can get another group of 16 in here so
we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 so all of these right over here
are another group of 16
it's another group of 16 and then we
definitely can't divide 16 into what's
left so we have two 16s we have two 16s
and then the only other place we have is
ones and then we have three ones 1 2 3
and we have 3 we have 3 ones so in base
16 in hexadecimal we have 2 we have two
things in the 16s place so we would put
a 2 over here let me do it in that same
color we would put we would put let me
do that same blue so we have 2 16s and
we have 3 ones
3
and you might be time to say oh that's
just 23 know we're in base 16 here and
usually you know sometimes people will
sometimes you know tell you what base
you're in but we're in base 16
we're in base 16 so this isn't just 23
this is representing 35 things it's
telling us we have two 16s and three
ones and it all adds up to times 16 is
32 plus 3 ones is 35 I'll do more
examples of this in the next few videos